It’s chaos on the streets.
People are running as fast as they can as
monsters and horrors beyond imagination spill
out of every alleyway.
A monstrous, reptilian beast had a screaming
police man in its jaws.
A strange statue was standing on top of a
pile of bodies, all with broken necks, and
a horde of flesh-eating zombies chased some
terrified civilians into broken storefronts.
In short, all hell is breaking loose, and
you’re right there in the middle of it.
As you try to avoid the legion of hungry undead,
you see a beautiful woman beckoning you into
an alley.
You run to her, hoping that she’ll have
found some way out, but when you’re in there
and alone with her, desperately clutching
the one pocket knife you managed to grasp
in your trembling hand before your house was
overrun by flesh-eating insects, she begins
to laugh at you.
The woman starts to change right before your
eyes - Her flowing red dress transforms into
impenetrable samurai armor, her features become
hard and severe, and a deathly sharp katana
begins to manifest in her hand.
As the anomalous swordsman walks towards you
on this, the most terrifying day of your life,
you realize that you probably won’t live
to see sundown.
One of the most terrifying scenarios explored
in the archives of the SCP Foundation is that
of SCP-5000, events during which the Foundation's
primary directive changes from the study and
containment of anomalies, to the extinction
of all human life.
What would you do, in the shoes of a Foundation
researcher during SCP-5000?
What anomalies would you use to kill people
or stop certain Groups of Interest from taking
down the foundation?
We posed this question to you, the viewers
of SCP Explained on our community tab, with
one caveat: you can't use any nuclear weapons
or any anomalies that can totally destroy
the world quickly.
So, without further ado, let's see what kind
of destruction you all wrought.
LeoWorld said, "As a researcher, I would use
the radio to make people hear the words of
SCP-4511/the swine god to make them sacrifice
others to his burning insides.
It’s good to let a less popular Scp have
some spotlight in this scenario.
Perhaps this idea could also be used for some
groups of interests."
This response reminds me of something my grandma
used to say: If you have to wipe out the human
race in order to destroy a horrifying entity
lurking in the collective unconscious, you
might as well get creative with it.
She was a strange lady.
Anyway, all hail the swine god, may his eternal
flame cleanse the earth.
This particular strategy would probably take
a while to have an effect on the population
at large, but points for originality.
Yissi Biiyte said, "I think a picture of 096
would make an excellent weapon against Groups
of Interest.
Small, lightweight, discreet, guaranteed death
of the target."'
Now, this is a classic.
If it ain't broke, don't fix it!
If you've got a killing machine ready to be
deployed as soon as someone looks at his face,
why not take advantage of that?
The only potential hangup is the problem of
getting the pictures to the Groups of Interest
without looking at them yourself.
Once you've got a system down, then you can
just spread 096's picture around and watch
the body count rack up!
This strategy is a lot like playing Call of
Duty, it also destroys lives with a Headshot.
Derek McDaniel said, "SCP-2501.
Think about it.
A telekinetic claw that can crush potentially
anything while keeping a safe distance from
any threats is a perfect weapon for stealth,
hitting prior targets, and more."
No muss, no fuss, just a telekinetic claw.
Great thinking!
GhostOfTheCove said, "Okay, this is gonna
take a while:
1.
Wake 239 up and tell her about the Chaos Insurgency.
Show her videos of their raids on Foundation
Sites, basically do everything to make them
look like the "bad guys".
If all goes well, she'll wipe them from existence
like she did with the D-class.
Rinse and repeat for any GOIs that come off
as hostile.
2.
Use SCP-038 to clone anomalies that can cause
death.
For example, clone SCP-4955, find field agents
who specialize in melee combat, and send them
out into densely-populated areas.
3.
Blast recordings of SCPs 336, 661, and 2284's
voices on radio stations all over the world.
Have 336's recordings be as long as possible,
get 661 to spread destructive thoughts over
and over on recording, and make 2284 state
that there's a safezone at SCP-2316, so that
people head over there and recognize the bodies
in the water.
4.
Airdrop SCP-469 into Delhi, India, which is
the world's noisiest city, according to Google.
5.
Using a front company, distribute pamphlets
full of instructions on how to survive the
event.
On one of the pages of the pamphlets, print
the descriptions of several deadly infohazardous
SCPs (1128, 2316, etc).
6.
Integrate SCP-3280 into the water cycle."
So this is the way the world goes out.
Not with a bang, not with a whimper, but with
a fleet of gaslighting knives, potentially
deadly radio broadcasts, a city crushed by
a mass of wings, and killer anomalies disguised
as life-saving resources.
And then the global water supply being slowly
replaced by sapient water that hates humans.
Is there a word for being impressed and terrified
at the same time?
Because if there is, you'll find my picture
next to it in the dictionary.
Camille Lartaud-Balosso said, "To ensure all
children disappear, I would stop answering
SCP-3034, the Counting Station.
No matter how well-hidden or protected some
kids will be, they should disappear eventually.
I'm also just really curious what would happen,
I find that SCP spooky and fascinating"
Well, that's absolutely terrifying.
I can only imagine the chaos that would ensue
once the adults noticed that all of the children
in the world had vanished.
You probably wouldn't even need anomalous
measures to take care of them.
Their paranoia and rage would do the rest.
This isn't the most efficient method, but
it's the one that feels the most like an unpublished
Stephen King novel, so you've got that going
for you.
Cheat Code Master said, "I always keep a half-inch
model of the original generation one Devastator
from Transformers in my pocket.
I could put SCP-914 on the very fine setting
go into the input, hold my half inch Devastator
in the palm of my hand, as the door closes
shout "Prepare to meet your doom!
Nothing can withstand the might of Devastator!",
and then I'll personally unleash my full destructive
potential as the 120-meter tall combiner (It's
officially documented in transformers lore
that through Mass Displacement Technology
Combiners not only become bigger than the
sum of their parts, but Godzilla sized)."
Before we get into the plan itself...you always
keep a half-inch model of the original generation
one Devastator from Transformers in your pocket?
Just want to make sure I heard that right.
No judgment, clearly you have a good reason.
And that reason is that one day, you'll be
able to use the Clockworks to transform yourself
into a 120-meter-tall Devastator and obliterate
all of humanity in the most ambitious crossover
event of all time.
Legendary Hydreigon said, "I would use the
nerfing gun in order to use it on the groups
of interest to devolve them into cavemen,
but also against the people we're trying to
kill as well, then let them kill each other
in territorial struggles, while they also
wouldn't be aware of attacks by the other
scps that have been released, making wiping
out humanity faster and much more easier to
get done before scp 5000 could do their reset
button"
I had no idea we had so many supervillains
in the SCP Explained audience!
Using the Nerfing Gun to Nerf all of humanity,
that's truly on another level.
Release SCP-682 into the fray, and things
will get downright prehistoric.
Nevermore Ghoul said, "As a researcher, I
suggest you Unleashing scp 053, the little
girl, into any large survival bunkers/communities
that enemy organizations have created to save
humanity.
Easy to sneak her in and cause a mass amount
of death due to her abilities.
As to how to get her co-operation in killing
all life promise her more play time with scp
682."
Okay, seriously, these are getting downright
diabolical!
Since the Young Girl seems to be unaware of
her effect on people, you probably wouldn't
have to promise her anything.
In fact, maybe it's best that she doesn't
know she's being used as a pawn in a plan
to wipe out all of humankind.
Why pile on extra trauma during the apocalypse,
right?
Silver Kuroma said, "Well, I have been a fan
of SCP for years now, so here is what I would
do:
1.
Get a hold of SCP-079 or the Self Learning
Computer
2.
Put it on a little cart that was used to roll
in the TV on school
3.
Go to SCP-682’s containment sight
4.
Struck a deal with it, since I know that SCP-079
and SCP-682 have a form of friendship then
it could work
5.
If the deal fails, then get SCP-999 to hug
him until he becomes way less hostile and
agrees to help us, the deal being that if
he does help us, then he will be allowed to
leave the facility to a more open area in
a certain range, and he will get a few Class-D
personnel as playthings
6.
Get the assistance of SCP-343 to help us get
rid of the menace and rebuild the world a
bit easier
7.
Get the brilliance of the smartest SCP’s
out there, one of them being SCP-049, since
this could be the pestilence he wanted to
eradicate
8.
Let the world know about the foundation and
help survivors and such, like this was a SCP-001
“When Day Breaks” scenario
9.
Neutralize or terminate SCP-5000
10.
Rebuild the world"
A bright spot of optimism in the darkness!
Not quite what the prompt was going for, but
it's admirable that you'd try to save humanity
somehow instead of just burning it all down.
You might as well give it a shot, but be careful.
If you're trying to save the world, the SCP
Foundation itself is going to be gunning for
you, and you'll be operating without the organization's
resources behind you.
Good luck!
Exi_M said, "Here’s an interesting one:
3008, the infinite IKEA.
Make signs pointing to it that make it look
like a shelter, and disguise it as one.
People run in, and they’re trapped forever
(or at least until they die to the employees)"
So rather than destroying humanity directly,
you can just confine them to an endless purgatory
of Swedish meatballs and affordably-priced
furniture.
Great way to get the job done while keeping
your hands technically clean.
Vlask Gaming said, "I'd Use SCP-2000 with
a modification that would inject all the clones
with SCP-008 to create an endless never ending
horde of zombies to release into the world.
if the site is never retaken and is allowed
to continue this process I could, in theory,
have a legit endless supply of SCP-008-1's
to swarm the world with."
The Walking Dead approach!
You've gotta give it up for the classics,
a good old zombie apocalypse with an SCP Foundation
twist.
Always R.A said, "I suspect humanitarian aid
packages will be deployed by do-gooders at
some point.
If so, slip in a set of SCP-178 into one of
the larger refuges.
Since third parties caught up in a 178 incident
are also vulnerable to attack: job done.
And since any sufficiently large group of
people will have at least one goofball among
them, this could help wreck major trade routes
during the early days or weeks."
I always had a feeling that the decline of
the human race would start with a pair of
3-D glasses.
Everyone told me I was out of my mind, and
that I'd have to leave my showing of Avatar
The Way of Water without a refund.
But look at me now, I was right all along.
Kirby Kona said, "As a researcher in the scenario,
I'd find SCP-743, The deadly infinite Chocolate
Fountain, and place it in SCP-914, The Clockwerks,
on Either Fine or Very fine, if on Very fine
it’s still able to be moved and carried,
I'd take it to a refugee camp and wait...wait
till the now improved creatures tear those
who are resisting the Foundation to shreds."
Death by chocolate!
Well, death by swarms of anomalous arthropods
emerging from a chocolate fountain, but that
just doesn't sound as good.
Either way, that's a sweet victory.
Johnrie18 said, "So, if the goal as I understand
it is to wipe out the entire human race WITHOUT
using reality-warping SCPs of any kind, there
are a number of options to choose from.
First, I'd start with SCP 2419 and let loose
the thousands of unliving D-class who have
had every trace of humanity wiped from their
souls.
They should be more than eager to wrack up
as high of a body count as possible.
Then I'd use SCPs capable of targeting specific
areas or population centers like SCP-923,
a satellite whose rays drive people into a
murderous rage, or SCP-2617, a Russian radio
tower that can summon an army of ice soldiers
to exterminate anything within a pre-programmed
set of coordinates.
Also, while there is no shortage oF bloody-thirsty
SCPs out there, including SCP-082 aka Fernand
the Cannibal, or SCP-953, the Polymorphic
Humanoid, I'd start with a bigger gun.
SCP-353 aka Vector, is a 26-year-old girl
with the ability to absorb, contain, manipulate
and release viruses as she pleases.
She also happens to delight in killing as
many people as she can, so I have a feeling
she'd be more than happy to help, even against
other agencies out to combat the Foundation.
I may have been thinking about this for a
while."
You don't say!
Thank you, Johnrie, for one of the most in-depth
and terrifying responses to our prompt.
And on behalf of humanity, thank you for channeling
this energy into SCP-related pursuits instead
of bringing about the actual apocalypse.
Between the laughing men, the rogue satellite,
the Russian radio tower, and Vector...humanity,
and the dark passenger that dwells deep within
every human psyche, doesn't stand a chance.
Now go check out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation” and “How
SCP-682 Tried to Stop SCP-5000” for more!